avant toute chose et au nom de chacune
et chacun d'entre nous bien évidemment
permettez-moi de rendre un hommage
appuyé à la douane française notre
administration de la frontière et de la
marchandise et de saluer l'action des
femmes et des hommes qui œuvrent
courageusement pour la protection nos
frontières notre sécurité nationale et
notre économie je les remercie pour leur
travail au quotidien et pour les riches
et échanges que nous avons pu avoir lors
des auditions et des déplacements que
nous avons réalisé ce sont 16 626
personnes qui assurent au quotidien la
sécurité du territoire et de la
population et qui font face à des
menaces nouvelles tant sur le terrain
prospère de la cybercriminalité qu'en
matière d'évolution des modes
opératoires des délinquants dans le
monde celui-ci bien réel mais cela ne
les empêche pas de saisir au quotidien
des marchandises et des biens comme
l'illustre les saisies records en 2022
qu'à mentionné notre notre rapporteur
des finances donc de 104 tonnes de
stupéfiants à la fois sur les routes
dans les airs par voie postale ou
maritime qui montre ainsi l'étendue de
leur rayon d'action le texte de loi qui
est au vote soumis aujourd'hui c'est le
premier dédié à la douane depuis plus
d'un demi-siècle et là pour ambition de
leur donner demain les moyens de
poursuivre et de renforcer leur action
au service de notre pays en effet ça
d'ores et déjà été dit sans intervention
rapide du législateur les douanes aurait
risqué de se retrouver privé dès la
rentrée de l'un de leurs principaux
leviers d'action le droit de visite
douanière des marchandises véhicules et
personnes dont le fond de mon juridique
a été jugé inconstitutionnel le texte a
pu être enrichi au fil des discussions
des échanges en commission des lois des
finances et d'ailleurs je remercie
madame la rapporteur Nadia et pour notre
collaboration puis en séance publique à
l'Assemblée comme au Sénat ce qui me
permet aussi de remercier Monsieur Alain
Richard rapporteur pour la Commission au
Sénat je profite donc de cette prise de
parole pour appuyer certains des
articles essentiels au bon
fonctionnement du travail de nos agents
des douanes l'article premier il modifie
la zone terrestre du rayon des douanes
afin d'en fixer la limite à 40 km à
partir des frontières sans permettre au
pouvoir réglementaire de l'étendre
l'article 2 qui peut vraiment être vu
comme le cœur du texte et qui court à la
réponse de la censure de 2022 sur le
droit de visite il prévoit un dispositif
qui est un bon équilibre à la fois entre
la sécurité juridique et la préservation
de la capacité opérationnelle des
douanes et je le répète je tiens
vraiment encore à le dire ils pourront
bien évidemment intervenir sur tout le
territoire et pas seulement aux
frontières comme nombre de mes collègues
j'ai pu constater l'efficacité de ce
droit de visite alors pour ma part lors
d'une immersion en Isère au péage de
Voreppe adaptabilité réactivité sont les
maîtres mots de leur travail comme le
prouve les deux minutes et 10 secondes
en moyenne de délai pour immobiliser les
marchandises
l'article 7 lui prévoit la création
d'une réserve opérationnelle de
l'administration des douanes destiné à
des missions de renforts temporaire des
services douaniers le groupe démocrate
parle l'amendement de mon collègue
Christophe Blanchet a permis d'intégrer
au texte le fait de permettre aux
étudiants réservistes de valider les
crédits ECTS l'article 11 lui instaure
une expérience de 3 ans d'exploitation
élargie du dispositif de lecteur
automatique des plaques
d'immatriculation les fameux lapis pour
contrer la sophistication grandissante
des modes opératoires des délinquants
dans la Commission des délits douaniers
les plus graves pour répondre à
certaines craintes nous pouvons bien
évidemment nous garantir de la vie
favorable de la CNIL sur ce dispositif
qui est donc bien encadré nous avons un
nouvel article après l'article 12 qui a
été introduit en séance de nouveau par
notre collègue Christophe Blanchet qui
ajoute les médicaments falsifiés à la
liste des marchandises pouvant être
contrôlées en conclusion
l'examen en commission puis en sciences
publiques a conserver l'équilibre
général qui nous était présenté par
Monsieur le Ministre et le Sénat et
l'Assemblée ont convergé je crois de
vraiment de façon très harmonieuse et
nous avons pu avoir des échanges
constructifs et très
productif l'objectif de fournir demain à
nos douaniers tous les moyens de
réaliser au mieux leurs missions que
nous avons partagé tout au long des
débats et donc largement respecter c'est
pour cela que le groupe démocrate se
prononcera en faveur de ce texte je vous